[Music]
hey everyone in this video we're going
to be discussing a topic that was
requested in the comment section quite a
lot and that is how are spells created
it seems like there are so many
different spells floating around in
Harry Potter which made us wonder how
and why is there such an abundance how
do we get to this point which is the
process for creating a spell we know the
powerful wizards like Snape are known
for creating spells like leva corpus and
Sectumsempra but is this something that
is achievable by any wishing wizard or
is it reserved only for those that are
powerful in this video we're going to be
diving into the creation of spells let
me start off by explicitly stating that
this is purely our opinion and that it
is not backed by canon in any way these
are just some theories that we have and
we'd love to hear your own theories on
this topic first things first I think
that you would need to figure out the
purpose of your spell that includes what
it's for why you're creating it and how
you plan on using it once you have
figured out what your spell is going to
be used for you need to figure out the
incantation of the spell that is the
words that your utter as you're casting
said spell in Harry Potter
most of the spell books are written in
Latin so my best guess would be the best
place to start would be to figure out
Latin root words that are related to the
purpose of your spell a good example of
this would be Snape spell that he
created Sectumsempra which literally
translates to cut forever
other examples include Lumos used to
turn a wand into a torch which comes
from the Latin word lumen that directly
translates to light
imperio which is used to forcibly
control the victim is based off of the
Latin Imperium which translates to power
this seems fitting as it alludes to the
power you have over said victim confront
Oh used to cause confusion is
coincidentally the Latin word in its
entirety as well as the incantation
confront a means to blur confuse or
jumble which seems very appropriate
given the function of the spell
as we can see there is a direct
relationship between the incantation and
the Latin root word however the actual
incantation in most cases appears to be
an adaptation or deviation from the
Latin root word this would explain why
it's so difficult to create or figure
out these incantations because only the
correct combination would work only a
truly determined and patient witch or
wizard would be up to the challenge of
figuring out what combinations work well
together having to first figure out the
last word related to the spell outcome
that they want to produce and then
through trial and error experimenting
with different variations or deviations
of the incantation additionally I would
imagine that the intent would have to
exactly match the incantation meaning
that if they uttered the correct
incantation without the matching intent
then it still wouldn't work I think that
if you had the desire to create a spell
a good place to start would be to look
at existing spells that produce an
outcome which is similar in nature to
your own desired outcome that is you
could start by taking existing spells
and adjusting them ever so slightly as
to influence the outcome let's start by
taking a two-part spell like expecto
patronum
expecto patronum as we know is used to
call forth a Patronus charm
expecto patronum literally means I wait
for a patron expecto translates to I
expect or I wait and patron is the
closest single word English translation
of the Latin Patronus patron refers to
in one of its definitions the protector
of a dependent which completely checks
out as far as the spell is concerned now
that we've effectively broken apart
expecto patronum into two sections we
can use those sections independently and
see how they might fit with other
incantations a good incantation to
combine it with could be finite
Incantatem which is used to end an
already cast spell such as effects
finite in latin refers to finitely
meaning that it will come to an end so
if we wanted a spell that would end or
get rid of the
chonus of another virtual wizard we
could combine finite and patronum to
produce finite patron by the logic that
I've provided above we could assume that
the patron would come to an end
obviously this is just an example and it
probably doesn't entirely check out but
I wouldn't want that spell in the hands
of a Dementor the only real glaring
problem with this theory is that in the
Harry Potter universe there are wizards
all over the world many of which who
speak languages that do not use Latin as
a root word this confuses things and
it's probably where my theory gets a bit
convoluted my thought is this in the
magical world where seemingly anything
is possible
the magical presence location and intent
of the caster accounts the wizard or
witch's specific utterance of the
incantation that is the incantation
itself is malleable in that his
utterance is geographically dynamic for
example if you're in China you may use
your own rude language to produce an
incantation that creates the same spell
next let's touch on the one part of
producing spells personally I don't
think that one's a part of the process I
know that historically some spells
appear to be dependent on the one
movement to be efficiently cast but I
feel that this does not adequately
account for the existence of oneness
magic which has been known to be more
prevalent at certain points in history
additionally we know that the wand is
merely used to channel magic and that
the magic itself is generated from the
wizard I feel that this alone is enough
to eliminate the ones involvement a
dispelled creation process as actually
casting a spell is not necessarily
related to generating the magic itself
perhaps it is just that there are some
spells that rely on the use of 1 to
channel magic while others do not
to summarize I think that in order to
produce a spell you need to be
determined knowledgeable patient
intuitive analytical and experimental
you need to definitively identify the
intent or purpose of your spell figure
out the incantation and then figure out
the harmonic combination of the two
what do you guys think what part of this
theory do you agree with and which don't
you agree with if you could combine any
two spells or if you could create your
own spell what would it be and what
would the incantation that one let us
know down in the comment section below
and remember help will always be given
at Hogwarts to those who deserve it
[Music]